les organismes qui offrent des services
aux autochtones à montréal peine à
répondre à la demande
et même si ottawa a présenté hier le
détail d'une aide financière pour les
soutenir
ils s'inquiètent d'une deuxième vague de
kobe 19 julie marchessault a préparé ce
qui suit chaque jour au square cabot des
dizaines de personnes en situation
d'itinérance ont recours aux services se
faire douch distribution d' aide
alimentaire de nombreux autochtones s'y
retrouve plusieurs sont originaires du
nunavik ou du territoire cri les choses
qu'on prend pour acquis une deux le soir
c'est le choix résilience montréal fait
partie des 13 organisations québécoises
qui bénéficie du financement détaillé
mardi par ottawa
les subventions proviennent d'une
enveloppe de 90 millions de dollars déjà
prévu au budget elle vise spécifiquement
les services aux autochtones en milieu
urbain itinérance santé mentale sécurité
alimentaire là où la demande est criante
ce soutien englobe une multitude de
moyens pour répondre aux besoins des
autochtones en matière de santé de santé
publique face à la coved 19 peut s'agir
d'appui les interventions en santé
publique dans les communautés
autochtones d'appuyer les refuges
d'urgence pour la prévention de la
violence familiale et la construction de
12 nouveaux refuges entre autres les
organismes le répète depuis le début de
la pandémie
la demande ne dérougit pas un cc tard
parce que il ya eu beaucoup de détresse
ou coup de
violence et on a vraiment laissé une
population se veut spécialement la
population inuite tout seul dans des
situations terribles robbie maddison a
eu recours à de nombreux services en
tant qu'autochtones d'origine crie dans
le passé selon lui montréal peut faire
mieux
montréal pour les par beaucoup mieux
beaucoup
si vous allez à ottawa et à toronto et
vous c'est vous vous promenez vous
renseigner sur les services qu'ils ont à
faire là bas ils sont bien mieux
organisés qu'au à comparer au québec
ottawa multiplient ces jours-ci les
annonces en matière de soutien financier
aux communautés autochtones il faut dire
que plusieurs organismes kring une
deuxième bague potentiel mais surtout
les besoins sont criants en milieu
urbain alors que plus de 50 % de la
population autochtone habitent en milieu
urbain ici julie marceau radio canada
montréal